static rope and Fire Snakes those are
two words that I never thought I'd be
putting together in the same sentence
but as it turns out juggling calling is
here to challenge all of us Drex here
from drexfactor POI sharing with you the
love of poi spinning and flow arts and I
am here for the review that I never
thought I'd be giving on Fire Snakes
made out of static rope huh by juggling
calling so let's go ahead and check
those out shall we before we dive in
though I just want to give a quick shout
out to the Friends of the channel big
thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyre
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
becklinen thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
all right so full disclosure here I've
never been a huge fan of Fire Snakes
I've definitely used them before but
they're definitely not my go-to when it
comes to fire POI now don't get me wrong
I understand why people like them
they're very attention getting they
create literal sheets of fire around you
rather than just small points of it and
at the same time they also limit the
types of tricks that you can really use
with them and that's always been
something that has made me hesitant to
really use snakes all that often but
juggling calling has a theory about this
namely if you apply the same sorts of
ideas that we're having right now about
fire POI Hardware that is leading to a
Renaissance in things like static rope
tecnora Etc that you can make spinning
snakes a much more enjoyable experience
so they were kind enough to send me a
set and I have to admit I'm pleasantly
surprised so I'm going to go through my
usual fire POI rubric here we're going
to talk a little bit about features
about ease of use we're also going to
talk about durability and burn time as
well as I'm going to share some personal
Thoughts with you before finally talking
about price
so let's start off by talking about
features
so like their other sets of static rope
fire POI essentially these are all one
piece what we have here is an aramid
rope um I don't know if this is kevlar
or techno I think that it is kevlar that
goes straight from this little ball
handle here all the way down into this
long knot that this is an interesting
kind of twist lanyard I don't know the
precise name for this knot but there's a
little uh basically rubber sleeve here
that kind of isolates the tether from
the rest of the wick and that I think
keeps the fire from moving all the way
up the tether as it is burning now this
has two really really big impacts on how
these POI handle and feel the first is
that they wind up handling remarkably
like a set of practice POI I've long
been a fan of the way that juggling
calling puts together its fire POI to
minimize the hardware and this is a
fantastic fantastic example of that in
motion basically it feels pretty
comfortable having a set of fire POI
where it just feels like it's all one
piece and the other piece of this is
that they handle remarkably well I'm
used to snake POI working in such a way
that the weight distribution is kind of
evenly distributed all the way along the
tether and that makes it kind of
challenging to do things like stalls but
I'm happy to report actually the weight
distribution in these is a lot closer to
classical or practice POI than I would
have expected
all right so next up let's talk ease of
use
so one of my big problems with snake POI
is that unlike most other fire POI
there's kind of no really standard
operating procedure for how to dip them
and that is also the case with these as
well the best work around I could come
up with was literally just to coil them
up inside of my dip can and pour fuel
over them I've seen other people use
squeezy bottles to try and drip fuel
directly on them there's a variety of
different different solutions out there
all of them have some potential for
creating a mess I don't think that
there's a single one good option out
there I could be wrong though if I'm
wrong leave me a comment and let me know
but aside from that all the standard
rules of fire POI apply that is you know
you probably want to like very very
quickly wring them out you light them up
you burn them make sure that you've got
a safety spotter there with you
um yeah I mean as fire POI go these are
pretty standard
all right so now let's talk burn time
so if you've got any experience with
Fire Snakes at all you will know that
one of the big Achilles heels of them is
that even though they're very
eye-catching and big and bright they
don't have a very long burn time and
well that's still a thing with these
Fire Snakes I found that I got an
average of about a minute and 45 seconds
of fire out of these before they went
out entirely I would imagine that the
burn time would be longer if I used an
alternate fuel like lamp oil but being
as how white gas is the most common fuel
used where I live I figured that that
was the place to go
all right so now let's talk personal
thoughts on these
so like I said earlier I actually like
the weight distribution on these quite a
bit
um I was surprised to find that as I was
spinning with them they were way more
comfortable than I was anticipating and
I have to say I was really pleasantly
surprised by these I'm used to Fire
Snakes basically handling terribly and
having to basically work around the
restrictions of the prop rather than
feel free to flow as I'm spending them
and you know the palette of tricks that
I had access to with these was still
relatively limited but I was really
happy to find that they handled a lot
better than what I was expecting sure
they were a bit longer than I'm used to
for most of my POI but at the same time
I never felt uncomfortable spending them
now as is the case with all Fire Snakes
I just didn't feel like they were a good
fit for doing a lot of tech POI tricks
or any of my really rapid plane breaking
or anything like that but a lot of the
classic POI tricks that I know and love
from fountains to flowers and everything
in between work out really beautifully
with these I was really really
pleasantly surprised by how well they
handle and of course they do one of
those things that I absolutely love to
see in any set of fire POI which is just
that they're put together in such a
professional and Sleek package that this
feels to me like the tool of a
professional not just something that has
been basically hacked together using
off-the-shelf Parts this feels like a
product that has been made specifically
for POI Spinners in mind and I love that
so static rope fire POI from juggling
calling are available as of the
recording of this video for 152 dollars
a pair there's a conversion there
between euros and dollars so the actual
price might vary by just a few dollars
over at jugglingcalling.com
um I really like these I imagine if
you're into Fire Snakes you might like
them too and of course if you plan to
spend any fire prop make sure that you
are using the proper safety precautions
to do so I will include a link to some
of the fire safety videos that I have
made down in the description as well as
up in the cards if you're watching on
YouTube please please please please
please please please
our community thrives on safety keep
yourself safe and you keep the community
safe did you get anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find it and to help the channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these lovely
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
helped make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
support and if you out there watching
are not currently a supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up you can do
that at the link down in the description
or the card that just popped up if you
are watching on YouTube there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
POI spinning and flow Arts to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you and if you'd like to check
out more of my reviews of different fire
props including others made by juggling
calling themselves I will include a link
to a playlist of those videos down in
the description as well as up here on
screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a little as well thank you so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow today and I'll see you with a
brand new video real soon
peace